esta ha sido una noche de ataques tanto
la región central de sap orilla y denny
pro como en la parte este del donbass en
la madrugada a las 5 de la mañana según
han anunciado las autoridades de sap
orilla cuatro explosiones sucedieron en
esta ciudad especialmente en un gran
centro comercial del cual se han visto
fotos sin embargo las autoridades rusas
aseguran que atacaron una fábrica donde
se construían motores para los aviones
ucranianos también hubo ataques en la
ciudad de escribir y la ciudad de donde
es original del presidente habló dormir
selenski hemos hablado con las
autoridades allí confirman los ataques
pero dicen que por el momento no dan
información sobre cuáles son las
instalaciones que fueron atacadas lo
mismo sucedió en la ciudad de crematorio
donde ayer pasábamos un rato y veíamos
una gran calma mucha de la población se
había ido de esta ciudad del donbass
esta mañana según el alcalde atacaron
edificios residenciales y lo mismo
sucedió en la vecina ciudad
donde habrían atacado unas instalaciones
muy cercanas a la estación de tren y
también siguen los ataques en
severodonezk esta segunda ciudad de la
provincia de lohan que está asediada por
las tropas rotación de stm está
sucediendo algo parecido a lo que
sucedió en mayo por la población que
queda allí muy poca está asediada lo
mismo que las tropas ucranianas que se
encuentran en el interior